[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen
sallys samira und cafés das machen wir
heute hier sein schäfchen muffins pass
seines osterfest oder n oder genau oder
fürs opferfest da spielt er auch das
lampe oder das schaf mit jockey quatsch
kommt also wir machen schäfchen muffins
die ila wird welche dekorieren unserem
ihrer mit bestechungen das heißt ihr
könnt es wirklich mit rosen und auch mit
kleinen kindern machen und die basis ist
ein leckerer muffins und ja durchaus
gesucht
miramax
die zutaten vorstellen ok also wir haben
mineralwasser und extrachor drops
perfekt also zuerst kommen jetzt die
trockenen zutaten in eine schüssel gar
nimmer den schneebesen noch auf sotschi
[Musik]
backpulver natron und jetzt darf die
älteren friseurinnen er in syrien
[Musik]
hier kommen die flüssigen zutaten dazu
noch nicht erst wenn alles drin okay da
kannst du toll warten supermarktes toll
sanierer 42 höher und vanille ist auch
schon drin ja super ok labs rührschüssel
festhalten
humalas mal durch die samira weiter
höher und wir machen schon mal die macht
in form
[Musik]
die backform schwer macht jetzt fertig
nein halt es reicht so viel zu wir
backen
zumal jetzt nicht mehr den ice trotzdem
her und dann kommt er hier in die
vorbereiteten muffin förmchen sie werden
ja die werden fast randvoll gefüllt
immer schön vorsichtig und los wie wärs
wenn das die samira macht ja und du
schon mal nach den manchmal ein paar
unser mir dann auch nicht zu viel leben
drin schon spacken die fest reisten wir
lassen mal die samira das machen
[Musik]
die maschinen sind es abgekühlt jetzt
könnt ihr die creme machen
so erzeugt man die zutaten wo ist der
frischkäse frischkäse da camera
mascarpone nehmen dann sahne butter
zucker man in der extrakt und sahen ab
dafür ist den frischkäse in die schüssel
geben
ja das geht schwenk macht premiere da
früher und wartet die die sonne nur ganz
langsam hat es mir zuerst geht das
immer schön rein
was ist also höher
mal hast du mal die schlüssel fest der
lack ist die sahne rein
von mira puderzucker da ist so viel zu
langsam
von 9 bis 10
wenig klasse heraus dass sechs
gestrichen für weniger ich würde die
creme einen spritzbeutel mit einer
großen loch schule hat für elias version
auch gestehen wir steht sogar schrift
noch so wir brauchen noch weiße
schäfchen ella ja normal dass wir jetzt
hier ein
und ich mache es jetzt mit adapter damit
ich später einfach die töne wechseln
kann und für samira schäfchen dann eine
gezackte teilnehmen kann
damit spart man dann die augen und mit
rosa den montag das war erstmal
us-version und zwar konnte jetzt ein
bisschen von der sahne creme auf die
muffins und wichtig ist eigentlich nur
dass die macht sich schön ob die
überhand und jetzt willst du einfach die
marshmallows und macht da außen rum dass
schaafs fälle
[Musik]
erst mal machen wir eine was ist denn
jetzt auch die augen machen
ich zeige dir mal 1 und du machst die
anderen hören lacht auch mit deinen
augen und guck mal da oben können jetzt
noch ein paar haare machen noch drei
stück wie macht das schäfchen 19
läuten
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir anderem uplinks auf
meiner weise was hast du mit
modelliermasse unter die schokolade
genau wieso also erst mit kugel und
standen nicht genau
super und dann 30 sie mit meinem daumen
zusammen was vom sitz daraus ein korb da
passt nur auf das du dir nicht zu
fristen in die täler dann nehme ich ein
bisschen modelliermasse schokolade und
rollt die kugel und dann freuen sie oben
ein bisschen spitz muss entsteht dann
darauf bist und dann mach ich unten also
dann drück ich unten noch ein bisschen
traust du dann und dann hätte ich das
trau dich toll mal machen wir noch
schöne augen und dann mache ich mir
schließlich die nase
ja und dann nehme ich zwei augen kaum
[Musik]
und wenn sie nicht halten kann man sie
mit zucker gräber festlegen dann perfekt
jetzt aber hier vorne eine stern schule
also in den freien gezeigte stern jetzt
machen wir einfach so kleine tupfer
drauf
[Musik]
ich geb dir mittel zucker kleber
was nicht gut ja auch die erlanger
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so die mädels basteln hier noch fleißig
weiter soll der dritte mal probieren
vielleicht sogar gewisse banken konnte
ja schmecken sie uns ja alle gleich eine
plane bis 6
doch mal ein haus findet ja und so
guardiola hat hübsche gesichter gemacht
jetzt probiert wie süß es sieht aus wie
ein kleiner urlaub
[Musik]
ja das ist wichtig für die castroper
auch probieren
[Musik]
den will ich noch fotografieren
aber das macht gemacht
ja das machen wir das fotografieren wir
noch heute gibt es eine große familien
paare und vorzubereiten
oh ja warte ich mal noch fliegt egal ich
habe doch papa papa ist halt immer so
vornehmen aber wir können auch ein
reifen also falls ihr auch mit euren
kindern in der küche stehen und backen
wollen probiert dieses rezept aus ihr
seht es wirklich kinderleicht
er hat super hingekriegt habe ich toll
gemacht die samira sowieso als große
schwester gersch super gemacht schatz
mit seiner kleinen schwester und das
rezept findet ihr zum nachlesen auf
service - blog.de natürlich könnt ihr
die muffins auch anders dekorieren oh je
ein kuss ein zuckerguss und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß dabei und postet
gerne um eure ergebnisse
[Musik]